for the many people who ask me what are
my favorite books on sales and marketing
my favorite book on sales is to get out
there and start selling because if you
start selling and then read a book on
sales it will make far more sense to you
than trying to read a book on sales
before you start selling because you
won't even know what they're talking
about same thing with marketing right
like if you want to go and learn about
marketing the best thing to do is start
learn how to run an ad you run an ad to
a landing page
and then start getting some people who
give you their contact information and
then pick up the phone and call them the
easiest thing to do in my opinion is
give yourself a slush fund right give
yourself a learning budget which is how
much am i willing to quote blow this
month on failure so i can learn the
skills faster if you just say i'm
willing to give 500 a month to learning
the skill
then you don't have this like emotional
attachment to whether or not you crush
it your first time because you're seeing
this 500 a month investment it's truly
that an investment in your education
your investment in trial and error
rather than i bought this course for
copywriting i'm not a millionaire what's
wrong right when in reality you just
have to get out there start doing it